- Good afternoon, everybody, and
welcome to Righting the Record
on behalf of the
Schlesinger Library
and the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study.
I'm Jane Kamensky.
I'm the four-timer foundation
director of the Schlesinger.
And the event this afternoon
culminates a really wonderful
day of meetings
with the panelists
who have been extremely
generous with their time,
sharing the day with staff
at the Schlesinger with lunch
with students from
across the university
and with many of our colleagues.
My role here this afternoon
is to get off the stage so
that the dialogue can begin.
I'm going to introduce
each of the panelists
much more briefly than their
important work deserves,
beginning with our
moderator and then going
in alphabetical order,
which is the order they'll
be speaking in.
But first, I want to say a
little bit about the impetus
behind this event, which my
library colleagues and I began
to organize about a year ago.
As the nation's leading
special collections library,
documenting the history of
women and gender in America,
Schlesinger preserves
and make accessible
the papers of women ranging
from Amelia Earhart to Susan B.
Anthony to Doctor Mildred
Jefferson to Harriet Beecher
Stowe, as well as the records
of institutions working
in just about every facet
of every wave of the woman's
movement and much else besides.
We hold more than 3,500
manuscript collections,
stretching across approximately
16,000 linear feet, which
is more than enough
to fill three
vaults, the largest of
which is housed right
here below us in the
sub basement of what
used to be the
Radcliffe gymnasium,
towering more than 20 feet from
the bottom of the College's
former swimming pool.
It's called the pool vault.
As a woman's history archive,
Schlesinger is in the business,
as the London tube announcements
have it, of minding the gap.
The history of women has always
figured in archives and museums
but it hasn't always
been featured.
My colleague Laurel
Aldridge recently
reminded me that not
very long ago you
could walk into a
major repository
and ask to look at collections
relevant to women and families
only to be told that
there simply weren't any.
Even today, women and
ideas about women, gender,
and sexuality remain
under-represented
in the documentary record.
This is partly because, over
the long arc of history,
women have saved men's
records much more often
than the reverse
has proved true.
Within this landscape,
politically conservative women
and grassroots
conservative organizations
focused on the household
have been doubly hidden
by gender and by ideology.
Family values conservatism
isn't by any means
undocumented but it
has been and remains
under-documented, relative both
to progressive social movements
and to conservative
movements led by men
and/or focused on geopolitics.
This is not by design
on either the archival
or the activist side.
I think our panelists
today are far from alone
in thinking about the legacy
of their movement work,
and Schlesinger,
likewise, has company
in thinking about these issues
among our peer institutions.
The obstacles, I
think, have stemmed
from a combination of path
dependency and mistrust.
And I hope we can begin to
remedy both of those today.
The gathering could
not be more timely.
The death last month
of Phyllis Schlafly,
in arguably one of the
most significant figures
of the second half
of the 20th century,
reminds us that even the longest
lived activists eventually
pass into history.
We're at a generational
turning point
where records of
the heated family
values contests of the
post World War II era
will either make their
way into institutions
or suffer the fate of most of
the records of most of humanity
over most of history,
which is to be lost.
We're also at a moment when the
necessity of cultivating trust
across the political spectrum
could not feel more urgent.
Two weeks before the
presidential election,
it seems safe to say that the
United States is not suffering
from an epidemic of civility.
Whether that's a laugh
line or not, you decide.
There's a saying in the
world of special collections.
Archives describe,
they don't prescribe.
Schlesinger and many, though not
all of our peer institutions,
see it as our duty to safeguard
as complete and multi-sided
a record of the history
of American women
as we are able to assemble.
It's our job to think
about the future as much
as the present and
the past, to imagine
how researchers a century from
now will understand our moment
and how we can help anticipate
that important work.
Our panelists this afternoon are
uniquely well-qualified to open
a new chapter in this dialogue.
Moderator Ross Douthat has been
a leading conservative voice
since before he
graduated from Harvard
College in the unseemly
recent year of 2002, magna cum
laude and Phi Beta Kappa
with a degree in History
and Literature, and
an honors thesis
on the imperial fictions of
adventure writer, H Rider
Haggard.
In addition to his bi-weekly
columns in the New York Times,
Douthat is the
author or co-author
of three books,
including, most recently,
the 2012 Bad Religion, How We
Became A Nation of Heretics.
His columns often wrestle
with difficult issues
at the center of our
conversations today,
the politics of universities,
and the moral legacies
of the 1960s.
After which, as he
puts it in privilege,
his clear-eyed memoir of his
undergraduate years, we quote
"accepted the sexual
part of the revolution
and put the rest of it aside."
Donald Critchlow, professor
of History and director
of the Center for Political
Thought and Leadership
at Arizona State is the
author most recently
of Future Right, The Forging
of a New Republican Majority,
and is, in addition,
the author or editor
of more than 20 other books,
including When Hollywood
Was Right, The
Conservative Ascendency,
and the important political
biography, Phyllis Schlafly
and Grassroots Conservatism.
He has long been a very
public-facing scholar,
appearing on C-Span,
NPR'S Talk of the Nation,
and BBC World News, as well as
in the pages of the Washington
Post, the New York Post, the
New York Observer, Market
Watch, and National Review.
Jennifer Marshall serves as
Vice President of the Heritage
Foundation where
she runs the think
tanks Institute for Family,
Community, and Opportunity.
In that capacity,
she oversees research
into a variety of
issues, ranging
from marriage, family life, and
religious liberty to health,
education, and welfare.
Marshall collaborates with
her Heritage colleagues
to explore how moral
values and civil society
relate to issues of political
economy and foreign policy.
She also edits
Heritage's annual Index
of Culture and
Opportunity, which
tracks indicators of opportunity
in the United States,
ranging from marriage,
fertility, and abortion rates
to labor force participation,
subsidized housing
levels, and student loan debt.
An accomplished
scholar and teacher,
Marshall holds a Master
of Arts in Religion
from reformed
Theological Seminary,
a master's in State
Craft and World Politics
from the Washington-based
Institute of World Politics
and a bachelor's
degree in French
from Wheaton College in Wheaton
Illinois, where she also earned
a teaching certification.
She is currently, in
her copious spare time,
pursuing a PhD in Religion and
Culture at Catholic University.
Michelle Nickerson is
associate professor
of History at Loyola
in Chicago where
she teaches the
history of women of US
politics, social movements,
and cities and suburbs.
She developed her
interest in the history
of American social and
political movements
as an undergraduate at Rutgers.
And then, despite my efforts to
recruit her to Brandeis, where
I then taught, pursued her
graduate studies inexplicably
at Yale.
She is the author of Mothers
of Conservatism, Women
and the Post-War Right
Right, A Pioneering Study
of the Grassroots Activism of
Conservatist Women in the Cold
War Era, Los Angeles.
She's currently studying the
Camden 28, a Catholic anti-war
group so named for their arrest
following a raid on the Camden,
New Jersey draft board in 1971.
Finally, Charmaine Yoest,
longtime President and CEO
of Americans United for
Life is now senior fellow
at American Values.
She is a second generation
grassroots conservative,
the daughter of
scholar and writer
and organizer,
Janice Shaw Crouse.
As an author, writer, and
political commentator,
Yoest has wide-ranging
expertise in public policy
and has served in many
facets of political life,
including the Reagan White
House and Mike Huckabee's 2008
presidential campaign,
before heading up
a national nonprofit.
She has appeared as
spokesperson or commentator
on every major television
network and cable outlet
and, in print, in leading
national publications.
She has been profiled
by the New York Times
Magazine, the Christian Science
Monitor, the New Republic,
and Mother Jones, among others.
Yoest holds a PhD
from the Department
of Politics at the
University of Virginia,
where her dissertation was
Empowering Shakespeare's
Sister, The Politics
of Parental Leave.
She is the co-author of Mother
in the Middle, Searching
for Peace in the Mommy
Wars, and is currently
working on a new book
related to modern feminism.
I've asked the panelists to
keep their prepared remarks
short, about 10 minutes, to
allow for plenty of discussion
among this accomplished
group of thinkers
and with you, our audience.
I hope that the
historians will tell us
something about their
research strategies
for uncovering the important
history of conservative women.
And I've asked them to
think, among other things,
about records they wish
they had had access to
and how we might change
those paths in the future.
I've asked the movement
leaders to think
about what we might call the
other side of the coin, what
you wish researchers
and future generations
knew about your
work and how you're
tending your own records
so that your story will
be discoverable.
Together, I hope we can
both discuss and exemplify
the work of building
trust with stakeholders
and with political opponents.
Let this afternoon's work
be a paradigm instance
of taking each other's
other side seriously
in hopes of a more civil present
and a better documented future.
Thank you.
- All right.
So I guess I'm in
charge here now.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
Thanks for that
wonderful introduction
and for all the labors
that went into putting
this panel together.
It's wonderful to
be back at Harvard.
I do a fair amount
of public speaking
and it has been a very long time
since anyone referenced Rider
Haggard or my senior
thesis in the introduction
or the history of literature.
I shouldn't say department,
but the Harvard technicalities
escaped me.
Anyway, I am here, essentially,
as a mediator and observer
who hopes, like you,
to learn something
interesting from these
distinguished academics,
these accomplished activists.
I'm also here as someone who
has some experience with some
of the interesting gaps
that separate liberalism
from conservatism
in American life
and what you might call
elite liberal culture
from populist
conservative culture.
I was not particularly
influential as a Harvard
conservative
columnist, but I was
the token conservative columnist
for the Harvard Crimson,
a newspaper then and now that
may have a slight liberal bias
in its editorial stances.
And I have graduated from there
to my current bad eminence
as the token conservative
columnist for another newspaper
that might have a
slight liberal tilt,
occasionally, in some of
its editorial positions.
And in both of
those roles, perhaps
my role for the New York
Times slightly more so,
I do find myself often acting
as a cultural go-between
for the group's
constituencies and positions
that I tend to agree with and
end up defending and the, I
would say, this slight majority,
perhaps, of the audience that
actually reads my
column every week.
So I spend a certain amount of
time explaining conservatism
to liberals, a certain amount
of time trying to explain
liberalism to conservatives.
And, of course, in the last
couple years everything
has gotten topsy-turvy because I
assumed that I would inevitably
spend my time, a New York Times
columnist, vehemently defending
Republican nominees and the Pope
of the Roman Catholic Church
to New York Times readers who
would loathe and despise them
both.
But, instead, I've
ended up as a critic
of the Republican nominee
and of Pope Francis
himself, which is a
very strange place
for a Catholic
conservative to end up.
So it's been a long year,
a long year for all of us,
I think, in American
politics, the world at large.
But we're here now.
And I think that
conversations like this
are immensely important.
And projects, broader
projects of the kind
that the Schlesinger
Library is pursuing
are immensely important.
Because the work of mediation
that I do, not particularly
effectively in my
professional life,
I think does try and fill a very
real and important gap that,
independent of issues of
partisan polarization,
intellectually weakens our
culture and our politics.
I think that we have a
level of the bastions
of our high culture for not
out of any sort of malign
conspiracies but for reasons of
self-segregation and inevitable
ignorance of cultures that
lived beyond their gates
sometimes have more
limited knowledge
than they should of
political conservatism
and, I would say, of
particular relevance
for this conversation,
religious conservatism.
I think that there is a gap
in the mind of the American
and Western Academy
where religion,
in general, and
especially conservative
religious values,
conservative religious ideas,
and the history of grassroots
political conservatism
is concerned.
So there's that gap.
But then there's also a gap in
the conservative mind, which
reflects, again, not a
deliberate refusal of knowledge
and intellectual life but
an understandable sense
that if the Academy is
a bastion of liberalism,
then the work that is
done in the Academy
must be inevitably
tainted by liberal bias.
And, therefore, all of it can
be set aside and all of it
can be dismissed with
a wave of the hand.
And, again, we won't make this
a conversation about Donald
Trump, but perhaps in the
story of Donald Trump's rise
you can see some of the limits
of a populist conservatism that
takes it's
understandable skepticism
of the liberal Academy and turns
it into anti-intellectual writ
large.
I think those gaps in
the conservative mind,
the conservative populist
mind, the liberal academic mind
are hopefully a useful
backdrop for us to keep in mind
as we listen in on a
conversation between academics
and activists about
the specific work
that they do, the projects
that they're engaged in,
and the ways that they, in their
own professional lives, try
and bridge those gaps, and
the way that they think,
as Jane suggested, about
their legacies and the ways
in which the strange realities
of being an academic,
studying movements
that regard the Academy
with particular suspicion,
the strange reality
of being an activist
thinking about your
own legacy and knowing
that it will be scrutinized
in institutions that
have a reputation for being
hostile to the causes to which
you've devoted your lives.
And then, finally, I think
the particular issue,
particular to Radcliffe,
Jane brought up, of sex
and gender is also
just a fascinating one
because it isn't just that
there is this broad-based gap
and gulf of understanding
between populist conservatism,
religious conservatism,
and the Academy.
There's a particular gap,
particular in comprehension
I would say, between,
in certain ways,
the academic, feminist mind
and the female, religious,
conservative mind.
And I say that
meaning no disrespect
to either of those minds,
which I have engaged
with from the outside as a
member of the opposite sex
for much of my life.
I was born and raised
by a mother who
is in the first class
of women at Yale
and cast the first presidential
ballot of my young life
for Walter Mondale
and Geraldine Ferraro.
And she was very insistent
that she was mostly
voting for Geraldine Ferraro.
So, going back a
long way in my life,
I've had exposure to
the two complexities
of the female experience
and the complexities
of feminist thought
as it interacts
with religious experience
and with the politics
of conservatism and family
in the United States.
And we had a lot of arguments
as a family, and most of those
were arguments
sometimes my mother was
having with herself but around
the dinner table as I grew up.
So that, I think, is the final.
That specific issue is a
fascinating fraught and vexed
one, and one that, I think,
is amenable to much more
interesting academic and
intellectual discussion
than maybe it's
experienced to date.
So, with that slightly
rambling introduction,
I see I'm two minutes ahead.
And I'm going to turn
those two minutes over
to the panelist in the hopes
that they use them wisely.
But I intend to be a
ruthless moderator.
They have a clock that they
can watch that will tell them
when their time is up.
Each of them will speak.
And when they're
done speaking, I
will try and guide
what I hope will
be an absolutely fascinating
discussion for about
20 minutes.
And then we will open
the floor for questions,
friendly, hostile, or
somewhere in between.
So thank you all very
much for your attention.
And I turn it over to
Professor Critchlow.
- We're supposed
to sit, aren't we?
- I mean, already I'm
the bad moderator.
But, yes.
I think we're in a
casual, informal way.
I'll be shirtless by
the end of the talk.
- Well, we don't want
that, I don't think.
- Probably not.
- I want to thank Jane Kamensky
and the staff of the archives
for a really splendid,
well-organized event.
So we've been treated very well.
And I want to thank Jane
Kamensky for mentioning
my book, Future Right, Forging
of a New Republican Majority.
I think it could be found in
the science fiction section
of Barnes Noble's.
That book got trumped, I think.
But, anyway, I want
to say a few words
as the political biographer
of Phyllis Schlafly
and use that as a
segue into talking
about the difficulties
of writing
a biography of a controversial,
political figure,
but also using those
as an opportunity
to see about
expanding collections
of conservative women.
A long-time political
activist, Phyllis Schlafly
who died, as was
mentioned, in September,
she's best known for
her work on her activism
in defeating the Equal Rights
Amendment in the 1970s, which
was a major defeat for
second wave feminism,
or at least perceived
so at that time.
Phyllis Schlafly's activities
in the defeating of the ERA,
I think, are of some
historical importance,
especially at the
time and today.
How it's going to be its actual
importance historically and 100
years from now, I think,
will have to be determined.
Her activities, though, extended
well beyond anti-feminism.
She was active in the
anti-communist movement
prior to this in debates
over nuclear strategy
before she became
involved in the ERA fight,
and then helped organized
the pro-family movement
and grassroots activism.
I think in order to place
Phyllis Schlafly into a broader
context, we need to
understand her abilities
as a political organizer
and personality that
went into that as well
as herself personally,
as a person that is.
The one thing that I think was
important about, to begin with,
I think one of the most notable
characteristics of Phyllis
Schlafly is that she was a
ferocious debater, anyone
who knew her.
And she was exceptionally
thick-skinned,
with a very strong ego,
very strong ambition.
She wasn't an especially
reflective personality,
thinker.
She prided herself on
her political abilities.
She saw herself as the
Thomas Payne of the Right.
She was quite
adept at balancing,
I think, throughout her career,
the Republican establishment
and party leaders, as well
as the Grassroots Right,
which was often at odds with
the Republican establishment.
Ideologically, and
I don't think she
had a systematic ideology,
what was important
for her was her
Catholicism, but also
the model that her parents,
and particularly her mother who
was college educated, presented
to Phyllis and her sister.
They instilled upon their
two young daughters,
in the depression, that
they should achieve success.
And Phyllis Schlafly
rejected a scholarship
to go to a local
Catholic school in order
to go Washington University,
the harbor of St. Louis.
And then she went
to Radcliffe where
she studied political science.
When she left Radcliffe,
she was a Republican.
But she was also an
internationalist.
She was a strong supporter
of the United Nations.
She returned to St. Louis after
failing to get a government
job, turning down an offer by
faculty in political science
to get her into law school.
And there, returning
to St. Louis,
she became politically active,
running a political campaign,
a successful one, in '24, that's
when St. Louis had Republicans
in the proper city.
And then she pursued a
successful career in banking.
When she married her
husband, Fred Schlafly,
who came from a regionally
prominent family,
her politics changed.
Fred Schlafly was
older than she was
and he came out of the
isolationist right.
And she imbibed,
there, his politics,
and she basically became part
of the old Right, very strong,
non-interventionist
points of view.
In fact, she told me, when I
was working on her biography,
that after the Second World
War and the Korean War,
she'd never supported another
American military intervention.
And that included Vietnam
and recent excursions
into the Middle East under
both Bush presidencies.
She became involved in
Republican politics as well as
grassroots activism.
So she was kind of
balancing between the two,
this kind adeptness
in getting both sides
to work with one another.
Many grassroots anti-communists
were very suspicious
of the Eisenhower
administration, for example,
and, later, Richard Nixon.
She told me later, after
I completed the biography
and it was published, that,
initially, the Stop ERA
Campaign did not
focus on abortion
because many of the
conservative women, especially
Republican women, actually
supported abortion.
This was a strong,
long-standing tradition
in our sentiment within
the Republican Party
up until the mid 70s.
They believed in reducing
global population as well
as population in
the United States
for reasons of trying to
address social problems.
She gained fame on
the national stage,
obviously, with the book
on A Choice Not An Echo.
And that made her
into a public persona,
which was later carried into
the campaigning of the ERA.
She was--
So I think to understand
Phyllis Schlafly is
to understand a public persona
as well as a private persona.
And, privately, Phyllis
Schlafly-- and I
know this might be very
hard to believe-- had,
exceptionally, a good sense
of humor, was a foodie.
Her daughter, in fact, runs
a major cooking conservatory
in St. Louis.
She was also a health nut in
the 1950s, eating organic food.
So there was this private
side to Phyllis Schlafly.
And in that private
side she was totally
devoted to her children.
She held a view that
really, I think,
has been misunderstood by
many historians and scholars
writing about Phyllis
Schlafly and her followers.
But Phyllis Schlafly
didn't believe
that women shouldn't work.
After all, her mother
worked in the depression.
She worked her way through
university and afterwards.
What she did believe is
that when married women have
children, their primary devotion
should be to their children
and not their career.
And I think that's
important to understand
about Phyllis Schlafly.
So just a couple points
and we can pick this up
in discussion a bit.
I had serious differences
with Phyllis Schlafly
politically, although she
knew I was a rare conservative
in academia.
So why did she agree to have
me write a political biography
and allow me to
have complete access
to her extensive
archival collections
as well as the personal
financial papers of records
of Stop ERA?
And there were two
reasons, I think.
First of all,-- and I think
this is important for getting
collections Jane--
there was ego involved.
She wanted her legacy to be
known by future generations.
And I think that's important for
trying to attract collections
that you're going to be
able to convince people
that they'll have a legacy
beyond their own activist
lifetimes.
The other thing,
I think, that was
important in allowing me to get
such as access to her papers
was that we established a
personal rapport, even though I
was in St. Louis at that time.
I hadn't met Phyllis Schlafly
prior to one meeting,
and she had given me a biography
written by a journalist.
And then I suggested to
her full-scale biography,
a political biography
by [INAUDIBLE]
I had become interested in
after writing on federal family
planning on the submergence
of the anti-abortion movement
in the grassroots conservatism.
So she understood
that I was a scholar.
She understood that
I was going to use
about 40 other archival
collections across the country
to check on her views
in correspondence
with politicians and
grassroots activists.
She didn't oversee the
writing of the book.
We agreed early that she
wouldn't final consent on it.
But she did understand
that it wasn't
going to be a
hatchet job on her,
painting her out to
be right-wing nut.
Just two other
points, very quickly,
is that what I found in talking
with Phyllis Schlafly, when
I tried to conduct formal
interviews with her,
she put on her public persona.
Very, very guarded,
basically gave me
what you would expect in how
she want to be portrayed.
What I did find in
working in the archives,
however, if I could catch her
between walking the halls,
I could ask her a question
about what I had just seen.
And she was much more relaxed
and would tell me things.
In fact, I realized--
and I'm not
postmodernist-- there's a
real problem for historians
working in archives.
And this was
contemporary history.
I think it's even more
difficult in the 18th,
19th, or ancient history.
But you base your
work on untaxed,
either archival documents
or written texts that have
survived from ancient times.
And so if you get a
series of letters,
for instance, talking
about an issue,
you might think it's even more
important than it actually was.
And I'll tell you a story about
that, of mastering discussion.
I think the other problem,
she was exceptionally
well-organized, had extensive
archives of about 50
metal cabinets
full of documents.
I convinced her that they should
be archived and be preserved.
But after I was
able to use them,
she subsequently closed them.
She was concerned
that researchers
would come in and
find things that
could be used against her in
her own political activism.
The archives are still closed,
at least they were preserved.
And I think her supportive
endorsement of Donald Trump
has caused a family
dispute within the family.
And so there's legal action
going on, I think, right now.
What's going to
happen to the archives
will be seen for the future.
So I think I'm a minute
and a half early.
So I think I'm
right on pace here.
No reason to take off
your shirt yet, Ross.
- Thank you.
- Well, very fascinating
to hear about a great lady
and her work.
I want to thank you, Jane,
for planning this day.
It's been remarkable,
really, and thoroughly
enjoyable to be
hosted well and to be
in the midst of
conversations that I
think represent the best of the
academic and civil discourse
traditions.
And, as already been
mentioned today,
those seem to be in
short supply in our world
today in our country today.
So it is a true joy to be here.
And thank you all who
are part of putting
on this important conversation.
I want to thank
you, in particular,
for putting together
this program, which
provides, as Paul
Harvey would have said,
the rest of the story.
We've been asked
to talk about how
the diversity of the
documentary record
could be increased so
that researchers would
be able to compile more
complete and balanced
histories of our times.
My answer to that is to take
conservatism on its own terms.
Investigate and present its
stated principles, rationale,
and aims.
Discern its internal
coherence rather than imposing
extrinsic theories on it.
Identify authentic
representatives and emblematic
expressions of it.
As the best teachers
remind us, we
should be able to
understand and articulate,
fairly, an opponent's case in
order to effectively engage it.
As the best
archivists explain, we
should understand both
sides of a social debate
to do justice to its history.
Indeed, public discourse
and civic harmony
depend on such open mindedness.
In the case of
the social history
we're discussing
here today, there
are some particular
obstacles that
get in the way of taking
conservatism on its own terms.
And in this light,
I was intrigued
by some concluding
remarks in my co-panelist,
Dr. Michele Nickerson's book,
Mothers of Conservatism.
She suggests that feminism's
dominance in recent women's
history may present an
interpretive obstacle
to understanding competing
movements and worldviews.
Quoting from Michelle,
"Has it, feminism,
become a central
logic for determining
the value of female
political identity
well beyond the scope of
its own historical influence
in ways that possibly distort
our understanding of women's
history by simplifying
representations
of human actions?"
She goes on to note,
"Feminism assumes itself
to be freer of outside
determinants than anti-feminism
to clearly see the world
through women's eyes."
Well, theories that assumes
sex is the explanatory factor
in worldview ideology and
political expression cannot
make entire sense of the
diversity that we see around us
in the world today.
We need investigative
methods that
acknowledge ideological
and political differences
among women and among any
other group for that matter.
So I agree with
Dr. Nickerson when
she concludes that we
need to investigate
how subjects came to see the
world as they actually saw it.
And that is, I think, what our
hosts here today are proposing
with regard to
preserving the records
of conservative individuals
and institutions.
So what should
investigating and collecting
look for when it comes to the
conservative movement for life,
marriage, and religious
liberty, in particular?
Let me mention three things.
The first is to take seriously
the conservative account
of the principles and
rationale for our perspectives
on these issues.
To begin with, this means taking
conservatism on its own terms,
literally in its
self-description
rather than applying
pre-determined labels.
It also requires attention
to its basic concepts,
such as its understanding
of rights, for example.
On the conservative
account, government
is not the source
of rights but merely
the guardian of
inherent natural rights
to which each and
every human being
is entitled by their
very existence.
Endowed by their creator is how
the Declaration of Independence
and how the framers
of the Declaration
understood the origin
of these rights.
These are terms
understood by reason.
And, indeed, reason is a common
currency to which conservatives
appeal as we seek to make
our principles and our goals
accessible and evident to all.
Any investigation
or collecting should
look for such a reasoned case in
the midst of any public debate.
In addition, religious
conservatives' perspectives
are often deeply shaped by a
biblical account of the nature
and purpose of human beings and
human flourishing and the way
that God has made us
to exist in community
as a part of that flourishing.
As a result,
investigating conservatism
means taking religion
seriously, not as a construct
to wield social power but
as a reasonable response
to the questions of meaning,
purpose, and ultimate ends that
face all human beings.
Second, take seriously the
conservative explanation
of our aims.
Conservatives stand for life,
marriage, and religious liberty
because of our interest in
the natural rights, freedom,
and good of all.
This is not an argument of a
self-serving interest group
but a coherent account
of the common good.
The right to life,
for example, is
grounded in the same principle
as the equality of women
and men.
The original purpose
of marriage policy
was to preserve,
as far as possible
in law, the right
of a child to be
raised by the mother and father
who brought her into the world.
The protection of
religious liberty
is essential to guarding
fundamental freedoms
of conscience, speech,
and association for all.
Third, discern authentic
representatives.
Any investigation must identify
accurate representatives
of a movement to study.
This requires an understanding
of the principles,
rationales, and aims, which I've
been describing, and others,
in order to discern who are the
exemplary proponents of them.
This is not to suggest that
a movement can be reduced
to a single figure,
or should be,
but it does mean
being able to discern
between central and
peripheral or fringe
aspects of a movement.
So I wanted to point
to a couple of examples
that I thought did a good
job of some of the things
I've been talking about.
One happened just recently in a
Slate article, The New Culture
of Life that ran on
the 11th of this month
by an author named Ruth Graham.
She's talking about the future
of the pro-life movement
growing support for life among
the millennial generation.
And the article
described a diversity
of different strands of
efforts in the movement,
but they were all around
this central theme.
And I thought that did a good
job of capturing the diversity.
I also want to
commend the planners
of this event for the choice
of image that they chose.
Pro-woman, pro-baby, pro-life
as the emblem of this event.
That does a fair job,
I think, of capturing
how pro-life, women,
and men would express
our viewpoints on this issue.
In conclusion, I'll just note
that Paul Harvey's coverage
of The Rest of the
Story didn't merely
supply a trivial
postscript to something
that was already a full story.
Often, it shed a whole
new light on the subject.
In the same way, taking
the conservative account
of the last half century
of cultural history
on its own terms provides
the interpretive key
that makes today's
challenges intelligible
and offers us the tools
for better public discourse
on these critical
matters going forward.
Thank you.
- Good afternoon.
I want to start,
also, by saying thank
you very much to the Schlesinger
and Radcliffe Institute.
I can't express to you what
a pleasure it is to be here.
I would have never imagined back
in the late 90s and early 2000s
that a problem that
caused me so much
stress as a researcher, trying
to find conservative women
in the archives, would land me
in a discussion on this stage
with such distinguished
company that I
get to talk about with you.
So thank you.
As a way to talk about
this problem as I see it,
I want to do three things.
The first is to
outline why I think
it's in our interest as
a historical community
to collect the papers
of conservative women.
Second, I want to explain,
if I may be so brazen,
why I think it's in the
interest of conservatives
to deposit their papers
in university archives,
particularly places that
are open to the public.
And, third, I want
to raise a question
about some difficulties
that we need
to address for moving ahead.
But before I get to
these items on my agenda,
I'm going to talk just briefly
a bit about my experiences
of trying to find conservative
women in the archives
to set up these agenda items.
So this goes back to my
years as a graduate student
when I was trying to do
research for my dissertation.
It was the turn of
the 21st century
and I was enthusiastically
joining a wave of new scholars,
studying American conservatism.
And unlike most other ABDs and
newly minted PhDs in the field,
I was also interested
in women and gender.
And I say most.
I had a very important
predecessor here, Lisa McGiir,
who's in the audience who wrote
another very important book
on women in conservatism.
I was actually interested
in how Cold War era
housewives of the 1950s
built important institutions,
networks, and organs of
grassroots conservatism
from their suburban
Los Angeles homes
and how they established
important building
blocks for the emerging
movement to come.
My earliest forays into
historical archives
were difficult, though.
It took many months
for me to get my legs
because when I first
talked to archivists
they would tell me
that they really
didn't have anything for me.
No collections on
conservative women.
There was always a but.
I discovered that there were, in
fact, women in these archives.
One just needed to know
how and where to look.
They would tell me
things like, well, we
don't have conservative
women, but we do have
this radical right collection.
That was at the Hoover.
Or we do have the Sarah Diamond
collection at the Bancroft.
And you might find
women in there.
Or there were the spy
reports of the Los Angeles
Jewish Community Relations.
These are groups spying on
conservative groups and so on.
And I found some
incredible riches this way.
But for the most
part, women were not
jumping out of these papers.
I found the papers
by finding the real,
live, breathing women.
Every day, as I combed through
the records of organizations,
government documents,
political documents,
I would keep a list
of names of women.
And, after lunch, I would
sit-in front of a computer
at the archive and I would
look up phone numbers
in the online white pages.
And then when I would
go home in the evening,
I would make cold calls.
I would just call people.
And eventually I
would get a hit.
And I met some really important
women, some really fascinating
activists.
I managed to record
their oral histories
and examined troves of
historical documents
that many had stored
in their homes.
And if there are
archivists in the audience,
you know what I'm talking about.
People who just would go to
events and collect things.
And this brings me
to my first point.
Why it is in our interest,
as a historical community,
to collect the papers
of conservative women?
Now, by historical
community, I mean all of us
in the business, scholars,
activists, public historians,
teachers.
Because this problem that I had
finding conservative women's
papers is the problem
of conservatism as
outlined by Alan
Brinkley in 1994
in the American
Historical Review
essay that, among other
things, inspired my research.
This article is literally
called The Problem
of American Conservatism.
US political
historians, he argued,
had failed to basically
explain the success and nuances
of the American right in
history, a problem he correctly
attributed to failure of
the "historical imagination"
and "basic lack of sympathy for
the right among most scholars."
And to further apply this
interpretation by Brinkley
to our problem
here today, there's
just no way we can fully
capture the national fabric
or political
landscape if we don't
seek a diversity of
voices in the record.
In that vein, it's
necessary to emphasize
that we need to collect the
material of conservatives
who we don't necessarily
see every night on Fox News.
OK.
So what I'm saying is it's
not just elite conservatives.
It's not just the
people who you think
of when we say conservative,
who we have to collect.
And that category doesn't
just include women.
It also includes
black Republicans,
Korean Christian
conservatives, and others
who don't come to mind when
we think of Phyllis Schlafly.
Second, although I'm
not conservative myself,
I am, nevertheless, going
to make suggestions here
to my conservative
colleagues of why
I think it's good to leave
collections in the archives
and to leave them in
public institutions
rather than places
that restrict access.
I think it offers
the best chance
of inserting oneself
and asserting oneself
into the historical record.
To make the papers of
a person or institution
available for research
is to put names
on a particular set of
events before scholars even
look at the materials.
It is, moreover, a
good way to determine
how the very meaning
of conservatism
itself will be
defined for posterity.
We historians, it is true,
have the right and duty
to produce our own original
work based on the application
of disciplinary analysis.
And it will often not square
with the ideas and intent
of our subjects.
However, to have influence on
what a collection is named,
to determine what
gets put in there
is one way of setting terms
before the scholar even
sees the materials.
Historical archives are the
first places we go for sources.
My last item today concerns
the internet, social media,
and talk radio.
Since it seems to me
that so much of what
constitutes the conservative
movement, and basically
all politics today, is
taking place online.
And what I found out
really encouraged me today
on my tour of the
library because it's
starting to happen.
The Schlesinger is figuring out
how to collect these materials.
And so I think that,
moving forward,
we need, if we're
going to document
the record of American
politics, its institutions,
like this one and
others, that are
accessible to the
public, where we
need to be able to find
the conservative movement.
And I would invite the audience
members, for example, just
Google conservative mom blog.
I mean, see how much comes up.
And with these
questions, I'm not only
going to point to the
difficulty of pinning down
what conservatism is and will
be, especially coming out
of this election cycle, but how
the archive of the near future
is going to represent
politics in the new media age.
Thank you.
- Well, let me start
by adding my thanks
as well to each of you for
taking the time to be here.
It's deeply encouraging
to see an event like this,
to have pretty much
every chair filled.
And for someone like
Professor Mansbridge
to take the time to
be here, Dean Cohen,
it's a testament
to your leadership
that this is happening.
And, Jane, I want to talk about
my deep admiration for you
in a minute.
Jane mentioned my
mother, and I wasn't
planning to talk about her.
But I thought I might start
with her because my earliest
memory of my mother
is falling asleep,
listening to the sound of a
typewriter in the other room.
And I love my
MacBook, but there's
something about the
sound of a typewriter.
And, to me, it's a
very maternal sound
because my mother worked on
her doctoral dissertation
after my brother and I
went to bed at night.
And I think that's
important for you
to know about me as a person.
It might also be
important for you
to know that my mother
was a teacher when
she became pregnant with
me and subsequently lost
her job as a result.
I tell you these stories
because I am an embodied woman.
I live as a woman
in this culture.
And I've had many of
the same experiences
that my liberal feminist
friends have had.
There was quite,
almost, an earthquake
online this last weekend
after the Trump tape surfaced.
And there was a
Canadian author who
asked women to tweet at
her their experiences
of sexual harassment.
And she started off by
telling a story that
had happened to her on a public
bus when she was 12 years old.
And it stimulated in me-- I
hadn't thought about the fact
that I had had almost the
exact same experience when
I was 12 years old when
a man exposed himself
to me in public, rubbed
up against me in a crowd.
And the reason I
tell you that is
because I had a visceral
reaction as I read
9.7 million women, the
last time I checked,
had responded to that thread.
And the point was to
talk about the fact
that, as women, we have
these unique experiences that
are-- no offense, gentleman, I
appreciate your presence here
today-- some unique
vulnerabilities that we have.
My daughter, when
she was in college,
was attacked by
a sexual predator
and, fortunately, she was OK.
But, anyway, these are
experiences that we have,
and I share that in common
with women, in general.
The reason I start with
that is because I've
titled my brief remarks
Trust and the Other.
Because, Jane, in inviting
me to come to this,
she mentioned the word trust.
And in our exchanges,
putting this panel together,
we've talked a lot about trust.
And that's a real issue.
And I thought I might tell you
a few stories that illustrate
the challenge of trust
from my perspective
as a conservative woman,
engaging with women's issues
throughout my career.
Because, despite
all of these stories
that I tell of holding in
common a feminine experience
in this culture,
I've been accused
of internalized misogyny,
of not being a real woman.
I've been told on
multiple occasions
that because I'm pro-life
I can't be a woman.
And those kinds of
experiences create a feeling.
It's a way of generating,
of distancing,
of saying that you, as a woman,
you're not really a woman.
You're the other.
You're this other
category over here.
You can't be a part of
our movement over here.
And so it decreases trust.
That's why, as I lead into
saying, that I do really
appreciate Jane putting
this event together.
Frankly, when you first called
me, Jane, I didn't trust you.
It took several conversations.
And it was really so
fascinating to me.
We had a chance to have
breakfast this morning.
And just before we ended
up talking about the panel,
we talked about a whole range
of just personal things.
We ended up talking about
some issue kinds of things.
And it's always
fascinating to me
when you can sit down and talk
as real people, real person
to real person.
There are so many
areas of agreement,
of agreement about issues.
That doesn't mean that you end
up coming out on the other end,
agreeing about what should
be done about issues.
But it's a productive
conversation
when you can surface
common experiences
and common emotions
and common challenges.
That helps you to build
a groundwork of trust
and a platform to talk
about how you move forward
and to brainstorm about
different ways of moving
forward.
And the reason
that, frankly, I've
always really liked the
concept of the other,
because it generates
so much that's
helpful about clarifying how we
can undermine our conversations
with each other.
Because what happens
when we throw away
round terms like
internalized misogyny
is that those of us who might
hold different positions
from the prevailing ideology
become a caricature.
We're not real people.
There's this idea that
somehow we haven't experienced
some of the same things.
And so suddenly
you're not interacting
with a real person who
has real motivations,
but you're interacting
with a cartoon,
and that's not productive
and that's not helpful.
And the other thing about
the other that's important
is that it generates an
unreasonable fear that
also undermines productivity.
I was absolutely fascinated
going through the Holocaust
Museum in DC.
I learned a lot.
I actually had
never been exposed
to the propaganda
that preceded, really,
the rise of World War II.
Just having that
wonderful experience
today of going
through the library,
it makes a difference
to get to see
the actual materials
of something
and to see the
pieces of propaganda
about the Jewish people
that were put out
prior to World War II.
There was this
generation of fear
of what their motivation
was and what they were going
to do to the German culture.
And I think that's what happens.
I see this a lot, in my
experience as a pro-life woman.
I'll read something
that is meant
to be a descriptor
of what's going on
in the pro-life community.
And I don't recognize
anything in it
because there'll be this fear
that permeates the article.
And I've actually sat with some
colleagues and leave laughed.
And I've said, have
you ever sat in one
of those conspiratorial meetings
where that particular agenda
was being discussed?
And I can tell you that
many of the articles
I read about these
conspiratorial meetings,
they don't happen.
And the agendas
are not as they're
described in these
more fear-laden kinds
of descriptions.
And I believe that's
completely rooted
in a caricature of who
the people involved are.
Let me give you an example.
And this is
light-hearted, and I hope
you'll find it as funny
as I did at the time.
But here's a personal
experience that I had with this.
So you mentioned Mother Jones.
So they were coming in.
And, of course, there
was a little concern
about the interaction
with Mother Jones.
And so in order to
hopefully communicate
a pro-women message,
I made sure that there
were several of the female
attorneys that worked with me
who were part of the meeting.
So it was me and, I think,
two female attorneys.
And I actually invited
my daughter in, too.
So it ends up being
an all-female meeting
because the reporter
was as well.
So I like salad.
And so we ordered a big
bowl of salad from CHOPT.
Do you have CHOPT
in Boston, too?
Yeah.
Of course.
So the female reporter walks in.
And I'm just trying
to be jovial,
so I make a joke with her.
And I say, well, hey,
since we're all women,
we're going to have salad today.
Oh, ha, ha, ha.
And she laughs and it was a
throwaway comment on my part.
I hope now you all don't
think terrible of me
because I like salad.
So here's the funny part.
The fact checker
from Mother Jones
followed up with our
media person and said,
is it true that you only serve
salad to female reporters?
And our media person
responded and said, well,
we're really a fan of
all of the food groups.
I appreciated her.
So, anyway, that's been
one of my favorite jokes,
is that I actually
really like steak.
But, in any event,
I really don't
want to repeat too many of
the wonderful list of things
that Jennifer has
already laid out.
But two points that
I thought of that I
would want to underscore
is as we interact
and try to understand each
other's positions better,
I think it's really
important to ask ourselves,
are we assuming bad
faith on the other part?
And I challenge pro-lifers
and pro-family people on this
as well because I
don't mean to assert
that this is a one-way street.
On either side of a very
contentious political issue,
you tend to project
off bad faith.
And, similarly, a
parallel question
would be, how do we
interpret motivation?
What are the assumptions
we make about why
a particular person is engaging
on the issues that they are?
I was deeply affected by
another life experience I had,
which was I had the opportunity,
after the Reagan White House,
to spend a couple of terms doing
an independent study at Oxford
with Dr. David Cook.
They have the wonderful--
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Thank you-- and a very
different learning process than
ours.
And so it's challenging.
And I sit with him
and he says to me,
so tell me why you're pro-life.
I'm like, oh, this is easy.
I'm off to a good
start here at Oxford,
because I'm a
little intimidated.
And I start talking.
And I start trying to
tell him why I'm pro-life.
And he brutally cuts
me off and he says, no.
That won't do at all.
Your first writing
assignment is to go
write a paper on why a
woman should have a right
to choose abortion.
And I was like, what?
That's not what I came here for.
And I have to tell
you that it was
one of the most formative,
professional experiences I
had in my entire life.
It was a very difficult
paper for me to write.
And I learned so very much.
And in my time teaching,
I've assigned that paper
to a few people,
tried to flip it,
whichever person
you're dealing with.
We need to challenge
our students.
our young people.
We need to challenge
ourselves to constantly
be working to understand
our-- I hate to say,
opponent-- those with
whom we are interacting.
Why are they engaging in
the way that they are?
And I'll try to bring
this to a close.
Jane also mentioned the New York
Times and the Christian Science
Monitor, profiles of me.
It's always really
interesting to go back
and see what a reporter takes
away from interacting with you.
But I tell you, in both
of those experiences,
I had really intense
conversations
with the reporters.
And their reaction was that
they had never really heard
the rationales that
I was articulating,
the idea that somehow
you could be involved
in the pro-life movement
because you were motivated
from a pro-woman perspective.
And, like Jennifer, I, too, was
really struck by your image.
Things like this
make a difference
when you create an event.
I can't tell you
how many events I've
been to where, from
the very start,
the imagery, the
framing, everything
is meant to bracket
you off as the other,
as someone who is in some way
engaging in a diabolical way.
To give us the dignity of
articulating our position
that we are pro-woman,
we're pro-baby, pro-life,
that is what I try to
articulate professionally.
And I appreciate you doing
that in the event poster.
And I think as we
move into a situation
where we may actually have
the first female president
of our country,
these issues are only
going to become more
intense as we grapple
with that potential reality and
what it means to be pro-woman
and how we engage together,
moving forward, deeper
into the century.
So thank you for your integrity
and your welcoming spirit.
And I'm very grateful
for this event
and for your leadership
in putting it together.
- Well, that was a
very positive note
to finish up on and
finish up phase one.
So to begin phase two,
I'll try and introduce
not negativity but
some areas of tension
that I think I picked
up on in the course
of these wonderful
presentations.
So I have a couple
that I'd like to raise.
But I thought I'd start with
something that I heard come up
in interesting ways.
Both Jennifer and
Charmaine talked
a lot about the
importance off-- I
think that when
Jennifer was talking
about it-- the idea of grappling
with the other side or the side
you were studying, whatever
term you want to use,
grappling with their
best arguments,
their real arguments,
taking ideas seriously
on their merits, not
just always looking
for the hidden motivation,
the hidden secret and so on.
And, obviously, Charmaine
picked up on that idea as well.
But that argument,
it's an argument
that I agree with and
find very powerful.
And in my work as a journalist,
I spend a lot of time
effectively, I think,
urging my readers
to grapple with conservative
ideas at the highest level
that I can raise them
to, which is not always
very high, but high enough,
hopefully, for newspaper work.
But that cuts in interesting
ways across the reality
that both our academic
participants are
talking about and embodied
in their own careers, which
is the grassroots versus
elite divide in any politics
but in conservative
politics, in particular.
Where you are, as
an academic, you
have an obligation not
to look for the weakest
argument or the most
sinister argument
that the other side
might be marshaling but
to look for the arguments
that individuals and movements
actually believe at the
grassroots level that may not
always be identical to the
arguments that are made
at the elite level, whether
in academia, newspaper
columns, policy papers,
or anywhere else.
And I think that this tension
is of particular relevancee--
I'm sorry to bring it
back to crass politics--
in the age of Donald Trump
where a lot of what's happened
in conservative politics
over the last year
has been a revelation of the gap
between what people like myself
and Jennifer and Charmaine
in different ways
argue and believe in and
what many conservative and
Republican voters preferred
to have argued for
and believed in by their
presidential standard bearer.
And this obviously isn't the
first time this has happened.
And much of the history
of Phyllis Schlafly
and the rise of the
Grassroots Right
reflects a tension between the
grassroots and the elite level.
So I guess this is maybe first
a question for professors
Critchlow and Nickerson,
but really for anyone.
How hard is it to
finesse that balance
where you're simultaneously
trying to take ideas
as seriously as possible
and deal with the most
serious articulations
thereof while also being
alert for the deep tensions that
open between populist currents
and what the elites say--
conservatism or liberalism,
it's obviously highest
across the spectrum--
is and should stand for?
- I think it's important to
begin with an understanding
that most historians,
scholars, and academics tend
to view the world through
ideology and ideas.
So they'll look for
offing inconsistencies
in ideas, whether
it's textual analysis
or in a person's career.
But I think ideology needs to
be separated from politics,
the actual nature of politics.
And what I mean by
that is politics
is about power, winning power.
And in democracy it's
about winning the election.
So you'll find politicians
and political actors,
such as Phyllis Schlafly,
are sometimes inconsistent
but not just driven by a
consistent ideological view.
When Phyllis
Schlafly, for example,
began her career in politics
in the 1950s in St. Louis,
she organized a discussion club.
And on that discussion
club roster were speakers,
were libertarians,
traditionalists, just
a whole mix of different
kinds of people.
So if you were in
New York at the time,
reading National
Review, you would
think the world
was being filtered
between this debate between
libertarians and traditionalist
and ways of fusing the two.
But out in the
hinterland, people
weren't debating
those kinds of issues.
It was passion at the time
about anti-c0ommunism,
and then it was going
to be other issues.
So my point is that I think
historians, too often, want
to look at political
figures just in solely
ideological kinds of ways.
And they want to also
look at politicians
in this kind of away.
And I also think, in our
political discussions,
we tend to often focus,
especially within the Academy,
on ideas.
But politics is about passion.
It's about winning elections.
It's about getting
those kinds of votes
necessary to win the election.
There's general, what we
call in political science,
political beliefs, a
general view of how
the world should work, but
not a consistent systematic
worldview.
And there's not a lot
of strategy, actually,
in politics, that is
long-term strategy.
It's basically I know
a lot of politicians,
and it's basically a
strategy a year out
on how to win an election, and,
often, it's closer than that.
- But the distinction to--
I'm going to take my privilege
and just leap to Charmaine for
one second because-- Or no, go.
Sorry.
Go with that.
- Sorry, I wanted to
follow up with that.
Because I think Don raises
a really important point,
especially when he talks about
Schlafly's discussion groups.
And it actually points
to an important tension
that Jennifer raised about
who is going to represent
conservatism in the archives.
Because when
Jennifer talks about,
OK, you want people who
represent what conservatism
really is rather
than, let's say,
maybe people you would
call the reactionism
of the current political
crises of the moment.
- I identify with
reaction, personally.
But, no.
But, yes.
No, no.
I take your point.
- I was going to say, wow.
But OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- What this gets to is the
fact that this becomes really
difficult. So when we
talk about the differences
between the grassroots and
elite, one of the things
that historians have done
over the past, let's say,
20 odd years is introduced
what we call social history
to the work of
political history,
where we're looking
at the kind of work
and the everyday
lives of activists.
And so we're also finding
non-elite actors and the work
that they're doing
in their homes
that you're not going to read
about in the National Review,
even though those activists
themselves are reading
the National Review.
But that's not what I
found in my research, Don.
But--
- I'm sorry,
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
- Oh, OK.
But in the 1950s, they were.
But they were also
doing some things
that elite political actors
would refer to as crackpot.
They had some ideas.
They were spinning
conspiracy theories.
In fact, you might even call
it reactionism at the time.
It was pretty populist.
But yet they were very
important to the emergence
of the John Birch Society
and the Goldwater Movement.
So it's really hard to determine
who are the real conservatives
and how do we decide whose
papers we need to place, right?
And I'm not saying
that what I have to say
about it is the most important.
I just think that it's just
a little bit difficult.
- This is a minor interjection.
Even to recognize that those
different strands exist
is a step in the
right direction.
- But you also come
to these moments,
and we've had one in this
election cycle, where
some version of the grassroots
that is not supposed
to be official conservatism
suddenly becomes politically,
immensely important.
Right?
And I keep thinking of watching
the Republican presidential
debates.
And how many times did
Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz
desperately explain that Donald
Trump was not a conservative
in capital letters, basically.
And that made a
difference to a slice
of the Republican
electorate, but not enough
to deny Donald Trump
the nomination.
I just wanted to ask Charmaine,
as someone as someone
active in a cause.
The pro-life
movement is obviously
a deeply political movement.
Any movement would be.
But it's a movement organized
around a single issue,
a single philosophical position,
a single idealistic worldview.
When you hear
Professor Critchlow
talking about the idea that,
well, this is just politics,
right?
I don't mean to say
that you're downgrading
idealism in any way.
And when you think
about the year
that religious conservatives
have just been through
with Trump, I'm just curious
what your reaction is
and how you see that playing
out, maybe specifically,
and the different ways that
people in your movement
have tried to negotiate
the rise of Donald Trump.
- I think there's more strategy
among politicians than--
I want to gently disagree with
Don's characterization there.
I think, certainly, they
will be more caught up
in the immediacy of the
tactics of whatever election
happens to be in front of them.
But I think that both
movements and politicians
who endure for
any amount of time
have to have a longer horizon.
And certainly in the
pro-life movement right
now, there's a lot of
ongoing conversation
about what the
next horizon looks
like in the wake of the June
decision in the Texas case,
for example.
So there will be a lot
of strategy around that.
And, certainly,
following November,
regardless of whether
Trump wins or Clinton wins,
there'll be a much
longer horizon.
- Yeah, I guess what
I'm getting at, though--
not to put you on the spot-- but
there a very specific civil war
over how you marry
idealism to tactics,
basically with the specific
question being should
pro-lifers and religious
conservatives more generally
support Trump?
And I guess I'm wondering--
and anyone can take this up--
but from the vantage point
of 25 or 30 years from now,
I mean, do you think
that this moment is
a real crisis for
the movement or do
you think it's one of these
political moments that
will fade into the
landscape of, oh,
that was sort of a tactical
debate that came and went
once Trump was defeated?
- No.
I think that elections are
always a crack in time.
They're significant.
They make a difference.
They are, in many ways,
an organizing structure
around which we
create our history.
And so it will be significant.
And it does make a difference.
We were talking a
little earlier, though.
I think that we
can, in many ways,
downgrade history by thinking
it's completely unique.
We go through these cycles
in American politics.
It's one of the reasons
that I study politics.
I think our founders
were brilliant in the way
they set up our system and that
it is resilient in its ability
to reform and recreate.
And I think that that is
what you will see happening.
But the other thing
about elections
is that the results do
matter and winning matters.
And so I don't think
anybody can really
tell you what's going to happen
with these different factions
that have materialized and
revealed themselves until we
see what the results are.
Because the results
themselves will
make a difference in how
people interpret what happened.
- If I may, I wasn't suggesting
that ideas don't matter.
I think ideas do matter.
But they matter in degree.
And what I was suggesting
is that the politicians who
are running for office, and
they arrive at policies,
it's not necessarily calculated.
I'll give you two very
quick examples of this.
There's a large
literature in history
that Republicans in the South,
after desegregation and then
integration had come,
albeit slowly and not fully,
that Republican strategists
decided to tap and orchestrate
campaigns against busing
and affirmative action.
And that was the
way of defending
this segregationist,
white privileged order.
And I disagree with that kind
of narrative in this way.
The Republicans were able
to win the South beginning
in the 1950s on the
presidential level.
And then, very gradually,
down into the local level,
it was going to
be a long process.
But where they
tapped into voters,
was primarily Republican
voters, was in the suburbs.
Newt Gingrich wasn't elected
from mule-driven, redneck
farmers but from fairly
Atlantic, wealthy suburbs.
The Republicans were able
to win the South primarily
on the suburban vote.
And, obviously, people had
moved to the suburbs, many
to get away from
sunbelt suburbs,
to get away from problems of the
inner city, which were racial.
But the major force, I think
drive, moving to the sunbelt
was better jobs, cheaper living,
cheaper houses, safer schools,
and better schools
for their kids.
So there was a racial component.
And the anti-busing and
the anti-affirmative action
sprang up in the 1970s.
And Republicans decided
to tap into those issues
as a way of winning elections.
More to the point, Phyllis
Schlafly and her followers
challenge the Republican
establishment on ERA.
The Republican's leadership
from Ford, and even Reagan,
although he waffled on
the issue, were pro ERA.
So, as the grassroots movement
and ERA movement spread
and it was learned
that you could
tap into religious voters,
white women voters who got
mobilized around ERA because
it had become a symbol attack
on themselves, motherhood,
their roles in society,
and a large buildup,
accumulation,
of what they saw as attack
on their religious beliefs.
Republican operatives,
at that point,
who were basically outliers,
not within the party
but political
strategists, decided
to tap into that in order
to win the elections.
That's how politics works.
It's much more
complicated, as I was
suggesting, than just
systematic, ideological, views.
And I think that's
important to understand
the dynamics of
grassroots activism
and how it plays into politics.
- And then, quickly-- I do want
to open it up to questions--
but I guess this can be a
question for both Jennifer
and Michelle in different ways.
But the idea of
studying, whether it's
the grassroots or
the elite ideas,
I noticed Jennifer was
talking about a piece
about the pro-life
movement that you liked.
It was in Slate.
It was written by Ruth Graham.
Ruth Graham is, I believe, like
you, a graduate of Wheaton.
And she's not a member
of the religious right.
She's not a religious
conservative in her writing.
But, as a journalist, it's
very clear to me at least,
as someone who's
read her for a while,
that this sympathy and
seriousness of her writing
on religious issues is
informed by the fact
that she has personal,
friendly, lifelong exposure
to actual, evangelical
Christians.
And so I wondered, both for you
as a professional conservative
and for you as an academic,
studying conservatives,
to what extent is the
imaginative sympathy
necessary to really
write about ideas
possible in the absence
of a real, lived, personal
experience?
And I think this is, in
certain ways, the big question
for the professional Academy
with its general, liberal tilt
as it approaches the study
of conservative politics
and ideas.
- Good question.
- That was the most exciting
challenge of my research,
I thought.
Well, when I started,
I felt like I
had two really good examples.
Kristen Luker's Abortion and the
Politics of Motherhood, which
was sociology when
I started, and then
Jane Duhart and John Matthew's
book on the anti-ERA movement.
And I have to say, Professor
Mansbridge, your work
was also very influential.
I think you're here somewhere.
I wouldn't even recognize you.
Thank you.
To me, this is such
an incredible feat
of scholarly imagination,
if you can put yourself
in the shoes of someone who
you don't agree with at all.
To me, it's incredibly rich.
It's an incredible opportunity
for you as a writer,
I would say.
And I felt like that was
the gift of my project,
that I could be given
the chance to do that.
Whether I succeeded or
not, I have no idea.
The only reason I
think I might have,
somewhat, is I've been
in some graduate seminars
where the professor would
say, OK, to the students.
Do you think she's
conservative or liberal?
And the students didn't know.
I was like, are you kidding me?
And so, I mean, at
least I fooled them.
But whether I was able
to really transport
the readers in the way
that I felt like Luker did
or Duhart and Mathews and
Mansbridge, I don't know.
But I think that if political
historians could do it
and do ethnography in
that kind of way, then
we'd all be very well-served.
- I'll just say that
it's difficult for me
to answer this outside
my voice as a scholar,
doing what we hope as working
in thought leadership.
I'm going to answer inevitably
from that perspective.
I suppose it would
be just to tell
the researchers and the
archivists out there
that our sector exists, people
who came to this movement out
of ideas and wanting for
the true exchange of debate
on ideas.
My work has nothing
to do with elections
and with the political
machinations of getting 50%
plus 1, those kinds of things.
And so it's neither
that populist thread
that ebbs and flows.
It's not the how do you
do the election formula.
It is day in, day out,
season in, season out ideas.
And in that, anybody on my team
who's writing and I'm editing,
I'm pushing them,
we don't do motives.
We do ideas.
I want you engaging the
ideas in what you write.
We don't do ad hominum.
We do ideas.
And so, in that regard,
I guess, that hopefully
illuminates something
that's out there
as a distinct category of social
history that ought to be told.
- All right.
We're going to take
questions for the next--
the clock is moving
and telling me
exactly how long-- four
minutes and 39 seconds.
- You can probably do 10 and
the fire marshall wouldn't--
- The fire Marshal
wouldn't-- Oh, 13.
You have just gained us 10 more.
It's amazing power.
So, please, I'll
just call on you.
Please, obviously, as
always-- oh, there's a mic.
OK.
Yes.
Anyone who would like
to ask a question
should rise, proceed
to the microphone,
introduce yourself,
ask a brief question
or at least raise
your voice at the end
so it sounds like a question,
and, above all, be pithy.
- I just want to-- My
name is Jordan Jancosek.
I'm an archivist at
Brown University.
I work in the John Hay library
in Special Collections.
Thank you guys so much for
that fantastic discussion.
I really enjoyed it
for several reasons,
but one being-- and
Jennifer and Michelle,
I think you might find this
of particular interest--
before my current
position at Brown,
I was actually the
project archivist
for the Hall-Hoag Collection
of Dissenting and Extremist
Propaganda.
And it is a collection that
has over 40,000 organizations.
Gordon Hall was a collector.
He was the person who had
donated the collection
to Brown.
He has since passed.
But he collected from both
the right and the left.
We have a lot of information,
actually, about ERA.
And we have both women
for ERA, information
of women against ERA,
Massachusetts for ERA.
We have information on
pro-life organizations, also
pro-- I guess not pro, but for
women's rights organizations.
And it covers the
entire spectrum.
But in order for Gordon
to give us the collection,
they had to do a
lot of convincing.
He was very nervous
about giving it
to a liberal organization
in a liberal university.
And I think--
- Brown is considered
liberal now?
So much has changed.
- I don't know if you
know much about Brown,
but it's considered--
But, in any case,
he was nervous about a
collection of that nature going
to a place where
it is perceived.
And it does have that
stigma attached to it.
And I think our job as
archivists and historians
and researchers is
to explain to people
that that's not what we do.
We make everything
open to the public.
We make all of these
records open to the public.
And I guess my question
for you is what do you
think about
organizations like that
and convincing
donators to release
their collections
and their information
and putting it out there?
You mentioned that it
needs to be collected need
to be out there.
But what about people
that are reluctant to do
so because of the bias they
think that may be put on it?
- Jennifer I'm going
to let you take that.
- Tell me the full name
of the collection again.
- It is the Hall-Hoag Dissenting
and Extremist Collection
of Propaganda.
- Dissenting and extremist.
OK.
I guess that's a
little wider category.
I only heard the word
extremist at first.
So this is a
conversation that hardly
enters the room in my world,
in conservative policy.
And so this is why
we're commending Jane
and her team to such a
degree is because these
are important questions
that you should know
are not being asked, perhaps,
outside the handful of people
in this room and a
few others that you
interact with at your schools.
So I do I think
it's a new question.
In some ways, we've
been talking today
a little bit about the modern
conservative movement, which
is only now beginning
to have papers
to relinquish and to pass on
to second and third generations
of that movement.
So it's an opportune time to
start asking that question
and having those conversations.
It will be exposure, I
think, to Ross's last point
that-- and the illustration
Charmaine gave earlier--
it is the face-to-face
conversations
that I think will
build the trust
to make that a potentiality.
- I was also thinking it's
important to think about how
you're going to organize these
collections in different series
to attract researchers.
It's interesting to me that--
What kind of involvement
did the donor have in
naming the collection?
- He was actually very involved.
Before he passed,
he was actually
organizing the
collection himself
with organizational categories.
And he had over 50
organizational categories,
which after he passed
away, we realized
that that was a little much.
But, really, anything
you can think of,
he had a category for it.
- Wow.
Yeah.
- I want to say that that
collection at Brown as well
as University of Kansas,
University of Oregon,
as well as Hoover, are really
important collections that
include quite a few women
in these collections that
date far back.
So what we're discussing is
there are collections out
there, quite extensive.
And the Brown collection
is just absolutely
an extraordinary collection.
It needs to really attract
considerably more researchers.
But just one other
very small point.
One of the problems is
institutional collections,
not only individual
collections but institutions.
And institutions really
don't think very much
in terms of archives.
When I was a guest scholar,
writing my dissertation,
a guest scholar on the
Brookings Institution,
they actually didn't have
an archives at that point.
And they had papers floating
around in the institution.
And I suggested that they create
an archives, which subsequently
did.
But institutions don't think in
terms of historical archives.
They might have
corporate archives
so they could look
at correspondence,
but that's, I think, a
major issue for any archives
because institutions want
to protect themselves
while, at the same time, they
don't think historically.
I mean, the Brookings people
who are quite wonderful
and gave me access
to their papers,
they don't think
historically at all.
And when I talked to them
about their archives-- and AEI
was like this, too, by the way.
Heritage came along
later-- they're like,
most policy wonks are not
too interested in history,
although some are
historically informed.
- The danger of history
is it might show
that your policy doesn't work.
So you can't have that.
- I might just throw
in there, there
is no real shortcut to it.
It's human-to-human
interaction, like anything.
And it's over time.
And I can't tell
you how many times
you will see events where there
is no conservative included
at all.
And it's that layer after layer
and accretion of lack of trust.
There was a study the other
day showing 0% Republicans
and I don't know in
some political science
something or other.
So things like
this is if you just
need to be really intentional.
Particularly, at
lunch time, we were
talking about how technology
can separate and divide us.
There's this increasing
problem of having your silos
and your filter bubbles online.
None of us are getting
as much information
that comes at us because
we do have more choice now.
So we have to be
much more intentional
in our personal news gathering.
But I would say that's the
same analogy for you in terms
of you're trying to resist
this increasing balkanization
that we have in our
culture because everybody
has so much choice
in what they consume.
- OK.
I'm a really fast talker,
so I promise I'll be quick.
I'm Lea Wright Rigueur.
I'm a professor at the Harvard
Kennedy School of Government.
And I know a couple
of you, so hi.
Good to see you.
So the first is a
really quick comment
that leads to my question.
And I'm specifically
thinking about another reason
we might think about this
kind of work being important.
And I think it's
important to think
about how these things
change over time
and how they don't necessarily
nicely and neatly line up
with partisanship the way
that we imagine them to be,
which brings me to my
question, which this plays out
in particular ways when we
talk about intersectionality
and when we talk not just
about women and conservatism
but about African Americans
and conservatism, Latinos
and conservatism, LGBTQ
and conservatism, Asians
and conservatism,
and on and on and on.
So I was just wondering, maybe,
if the panel could comment
on some of the ways
that we can think
about an archival
perspective of getting
to those narratives that are
really, really hard to get to.
And, particularly,
I'll just give you
an example that I'm
familiar with, getting
the papers of black women who
are conservative is really,
really, really hard.
Not because black women aren't
necessarily conservative,
in fact they are.
There are streams of
them and strains of them,
but because that
conservatism rarely
translates into partisanship.
So the assumption is, or
the accurate assumption
is, that black women are
the least likely to vote
Republican.
But actually, when we
look at conservatives,
self-identified
conservatives, they
are most likely
to be Black women.
So how do you
solve that problem?
Panel?
- I'm sure many people in the
room know you here, at Harvard.
But you're just not
being a good academic.
You need to put a
plug-in for your book.
It's a really quite good book.
- I wrote a book called
The Loneliness of the Black
Republican.
It's not a memoir, but it's a
scholarly look at black voters,
race in the Republican
Party, and conservatism,
1936 through roughly 1981.
And starting round two in
looking at similar things,
1981 to present day.
- You're on your way.
- Number one, let's
just underline the fact
that you're pointing out an
important research methodology
question for all of
conservatism, which
those are not
synonymous categories,
conservative and Republican.
So, number one, we need to
get that category straight.
And then number two, heartily
concur with what you're saying.
And so I guess, as
conversations of this type
are starting with
all conservatives,
the diversity of
those conversations
needs to be kept in mind.
- Yeah.
So I am thinking, first of
all, through personal papers
of particular women.
Also through nonpartisan
organizations of women
who-- and you might
know of some--
don't identify as Republican
but might identify
in more conservative terms.
And you better
than anybody might
know what those terms were,
even if it wasn't conservative.
So, from my work, women would
call themselves patriotic.
That was their word
for conservative
before conservatism
was a movement.
And so when we
raise this question
of how do you
define conservatism,
you would be one
of the people that
could help try and identify
and set those terms.
Do you have any ideas of
what those terms might be?
- I mean, there are a
lot of different terms.
I know we're short
on time, but I
think it's worth
thinking about how
some of these organizations
that identify as, like you said,
patriotic or identifying
coalesce around certain issues
but then argue that they're
nonpartisan or political
or what have you,
are undergirded
by a number of
these people that we
see doing this kind of work
that, again, doesn't translate
into partisanship.
I also think it's
worth looking within--
and that's the grassroots part--
looking at a top-down approach.
And so looking at how certain
policy initiatives are
developed, political
initiatives,
program initiatives that don't
necessarily look on their
face a particular way.
But when we look at
the nuts and bolts--
and, again, maybe this is a plug
for the Kennedy School-- of how
these things are
developed, it's not
that it's republican-democrat,
but instead
people who are coalescing
around very specific ideas.
And I do think it's important as
we think through these things.
In particular, when we think
about intersectionality
and when we're within this
conversation on conservatism,
we tend to think of these
various racial groups.
But especially amongst
this emerging conversation
on LGBTQ issues and conservatism
and how they're intersecting
in very different ways.
- I'm going to try and
squeeze in one last question
with permission from
the powers that be.
- Thank you very much.
I'm a 45-year-old mother
of three daughters.
And I want to thank
you all for this panel.
I saw the billboard up on
the midst of Harvard yard,
amidst my lunch
hour during work.
And I'd like to speak because
abortion, I don't really think,
falls between,
necessarily, party lines.
Because life circumstances
can reach a vortex.
And it can create a very
difficult and complex
confluence of circumstances.
And what I would
like to speak to
is how there is a barbell
effect within abortion
within our country that
no one wants to discuss.
And if we're going to talk
about archival records,
where are the
archives of those who
have been through abortions?
Because abortion in our society
is considered forbidden grief.
It is not one that
can be vocalized.
It is not one that you can talk
about in public with friends.
It is not one that is for
open dinner discussion.
It's not even one where, in
the pulpits of our churches,
nationwide, our own
religious leaders
feel comfortable addressing the
constituents and parishioners
within our diocese.
So it's a very multi-faceted
and, obviously, complex
condition and
tragic circumstance.
But the barbell effect, the
end result, is the same.
For those abortions that
occur between 18 and 25,
it's usually from many
different circumstances
than for those that
occur between 35 and 50.
And if you study
abortions, you'll
see that there's a great
number in that bracket that
fall towards single women
that it's not for them.
They don't want to have
a child and they're
pursuing their collegiate
career and academics.
And then it thins out.
And then you have
fetal abnormalities.
You have family make-up.
There can be gender
discrimination that goes on
within a family if it's a family
of, say, three boys or two
boys or three girls and there's
an unexpected pregnancy.
And these are real
issues that no one is--
- They are, indeed.
I'm just wondering if there's
one particular aspect,
if it's the archival aspect,
the nature of stories
and narratives about the
experience of abortion
that I could just have
the panel address.
Would that be the issue?
- Yes.
I would like to know where
these archives are held.
- OK.
Well, if I could just--
both that specific
question but also more,
generally, for anyone,
anyone on the panel-- I
think the issue of abortion,
in particular, so
much of this surface
political debate coexists
with these hidden stories
or stories that exist.
In my personal
experience, I would
say I encounter the
most stories of abortion
either in very explicitly
feminist writing
or very explicitly
regretful project,
Rachel-style, pro-life writing.
Those are the two
places, both of them
clearly outside the
mainstream media.
But, please.
- And I was going to say, unless
historians can correct me,
but we don't have
much documentation
in US women's and gender history
on what you're talking about.
There is a book coming out with
the University of California
Press by Jennifer Holland on
the history of abortion crisis
centers.
It's not going to be out
in the next year or so.
But there is coverage of much
of the experience and testimony
that you're talking about.
And it does fill
in some of this gap
in the historical literature.
But because of the
problem of the fact
that we can't access medical
records where women talk
about these things,
it's really only going
to be in those places
where women have testified,
often in intimate or
religious settings,
where we can find their voices.
And it represents a challenge
to us as a historical community.
I don't know of any
historical archival sources.
And I'm--
- And my question is because
do they not exist for a reason?
And, secondly, I'd
like to just say
that I admire the
course and topic
of the paper, the dissertation,
that you have to give.
And as it pertains to our
Republican-forced candidate
that we all have this
upcoming election,
we have life before birth and
then there's life after birth.
And I would like to say that
the idea of this person taking
office-- I have three
daughters that are in a very
diverse public school.
- I appreciate it very
much, but I'm afraid
that as my role as
moderator is not
to end with a condemnation
of Donald Trump
but to end by
thanking the panel.
And thanking you
so much for raising
a very important question.
So thank you.
And we thank the panel.
Thank you all so
much for coming.